all right Gabriel start from the  beginning we arrived in the Venice safe  house and set up surveillance on the  manor we executed our plan under cover  of darkness  you sure you want to hear about this  check you haven't left me much choice  whatever happened to plausible  deniability little late for that tell me  what actually happened  well Jack that's one hell of a story  every one through the breach we're  getting out of here  the extraction point right away so much  for keeping a low profile  do you know that a rescue someone deal  without a Dustin keep your distance from  her  feels like talon is mobilizing an entire  army to stop us  what about you anything to add where do  you want me to start